[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
US-Präsident beiden hatte seine
Landsleute schon gestern gewarnt wenn
sie zu Weihnachten verreisen wollen tun
Sie es besser jetzt sofort danach werde
das in weiten Teilen des Landes nicht
mehr möglich sein und man Strande
irgendwo im Schneesturm es ist ernst
sagte der Präsident und so dramatisch
ist es nun auch gekommen eine arktische
Kaltfront mit
Rekordtemperaturen von bis zu minus 45
Grad und schweren Stürmen zieht über die
USA ein lebensgefährliches Extremwetter
Claudia Bates Bericht
minus 20 Grad am Lake to lose ganz im
Norden in Minnesota in fast himmlischer
Schönheit liegt der See in klirrender
Kälte nur das Rauschen des Windes ist zu
hören
mehr als 200 Millionen Menschen aber
zwei Drittel der US-Bevölkerung stehen
vor dem eisigsten Weihnachten seit
Jahrzehnten innerhalb von Stunden sind
die Temperaturen um 30 40 Grad gesunken
zum Teil auf unter minus 40 Grad
es ist ernsthaft und Gefährlichkeit ich
würde jedem raten wenn du nicht draußen
sein musst geh nicht raus und wenn doch
musst du dich richtig warm einpacken
Whiteout heißt das wenn der Schnee nur
noch eine weiße Wand ist die Sicht aus
dem Auto gleich null es ist die
Hauptreisezeit aber auf vielen Straßen
herrscht Stillstand weil sie zugeschneit
und geschlossen sind oder wegen teils
dramatischer Unfälle
mancher kleine Hügel wird zum
unüberwindbaren Hindernis und zu einer
gefährlichen Rutschbahn an vielen
Flughäfen herrscht völliges Chaos
Flugzeuge bleiben am Boden viele tausend
Flüge wurden abgesagt Reisepläne sind
hinfällig
wir haben noch etwas Hoffnung aber
glauben nicht dass wir loskommen
besonders dramatisch sind diese
Weihnachtstage für jene die kein Zuhause
haben deren Dach über dem Kopf lediglich
eine dünne Zeltplane ist selbst hier im
Süden der USA in Texas
Hilfsorganisationen Rücken an mit warmer
Suppe aber wer heute Nacht nicht
irgendwo unterschlupf findet hat in
manchen Gegenden kaum eine
Überlebenschance die Notunterkünfte
haben sich deshalb auf viele Hilfe
suchende vorbereitet
wir werden heute Nacht voll ausgelastet
sein wir haben mehr Platz als sonst
geschaffen wir wollen sicher sein dass
jeder Schutz vor der Kälte findet
die alten hölzernen Masken knicken um
bereits jetzt sind mehr als eineinhalb
Millionen Haushalte ohne Strom Propangas
ist sehr gefragt als die Menschen sich
in letzter Minute noch mit dem
wichtigsten eindecken
so vieles ist uns sehr wichtig in dieser
Zeit unsere Traditionen unsere liebsten
aber das allerwichtigste ist sicher zu
sein
und wer in Sicherheit ist kann den
eisigen Temperaturen schöne Seiten
abgewinnen kochendes Wasser wird sofort
zu Schnee und ein nasses T-Shirt hart
wie ein Brett über mehr als 3000 km
erstreckt sich der arktische Wintersturm
kaum zu glauben dass die Temperaturen
bereits am Wochenende wieder um bis zu
30 Grad steigen sollen
wladimir Putin hat erstmals öffentlich
das Wort Krieg in den Mund genommen das
in Russland ja bislang verboten und
betonen Gefängnisstrafen belegt ist
vielleicht ist ihm das versehentlich
herausgerutscht ein Oppositionspolitiker
aus St Petersburg war jedenfalls mutig
genug den Präsidenten dafür anzuzeigen
der Krieg wird auch über Weihnachten
nicht pausieren nach orthodoxen
julianischen Kalender ist Weihnachten ja
eigentlich eh erst am 7 Januar doch
immer mehr Ukraine haben sich auch bei
Weihnachten den besten zugewandt Ariane
Güdel hat geflüchtete gefragt wie sie
diese Zeit nun in Deutschland erleben
die kleine Michaela war noch nicht
geboren als ihre Mutter hochschwanger
aus Grimmen Schug inmitten der Ukraine
flüchtete und in Düsseldorf landete für
die alleinerziehende Alexandra ist es
das erste Weihnachten ohne Eltern und
Geschwister ihr größter Wunsch für alle
ukrainische Leute ich glaube alle
Menschen dann
diese schreckliche Krieg wird bald
vorbei wir hoffen dann Frieden wird und
alle könnten zurück nach Ukraine fahren
die 34-Jährige hat Heimweh aber fühlt
sich nicht einsam viele Menschen hier
würden ihr helfen an Heiligabend sind
Mutter und Tochter bei deutschen
Freunden eingeladen eigentlich feiern
Ukraine erst am 7 Januar Weihnachten
nach dem orthodoxen Kalender wie die
Russen dieses Jahr ist vieles anders
dieses Krieg wir müssen alles trennen
mit russischen Traditionen und
verbinden oder einsetzen sich mit
europäische eine Meinung die viele
Ukrainer teile mir chaika ist Priester
der orthodoxen ukrainischen Kirche in
Deutschland in seiner Kölner Gemeinde
hat aber Facebook abstimmen lassen 16
000 Ukraine haben sich beteiligt und
sich mehrheitlich für Weihnachten nach
dem neuen Kalender entschieden
[Musik]
man möchte nicht zusammen mit der Kirche
des Landes das Ukraine angegriffen hat
zusammenarbeiten dieses Jahr werden
orthodoxe Ukraine zum ersten Mal in
Deutschland am 24 in der Kirche feiern
wir wollen zeigen was für glauben und
dass sie mit der ganzen westlichen Welt
und Europa mitgeht
der Krieg hat das beeinflusst wir haben
früher Weihnachten am 7 januar gefeiert
aber das ist für uns heute zu nah an
Russland
durch sie für Gläubige die an orthodoxen
Traditionen hängen soll es übrigens auch
im Januar Gottesdienste geben die Frage
wie Weihnachten gefeiert wird ist dieses
Jahr ohnehin für viele zweitrangig denn
Weihnachtszeit ist auch Winterzeit und
Ukrainer sorgen sich um die die in der
Heimat zurückgeblieben sind unermüdlich
Sammeln und Sortieren sie wie hier in
Düsseldorf Hilfsgüter die dringend
gebraucht werden
alles was mit Heizung zu tun hat quasi
Generatoren natürlich Kerzen wir sammeln
auch altwachsen warme Sachen sind so
wichtig auch über die Feiertage werden
sie weiterarbeiten Alexandra hofft dass
ihre Tochter nächste Weihnachten in
Frieden in der Ukraine feiern kann damit
ist sie nicht allein das Hoffen tausende
und live in Kiew ist unsere reporterin
Anne Brühl Anne wie erlebst du die Stadt
heute Abend findet sich überhaupt etwas
vor weihnachtliches dort in diesen
Zeiten
da muss man schon ziemlich nach suchen
und wenn hat es auch immer irgendwie mit
dem Krieg zu tun der große
Weihnachtsbaum der hier vor der Sophia
Kathedrale im Zentrum von Kiew steht der
trägt den offiziellen Titel
Weihnachtsbaum der Unbesiegbarkeit die
Weihnachtsbeleuchtung die gibt es
eigentlich nicht sie bleibt aus der nach
wie vor gibt es ja die Angriffe der
Russen auf die Infrastruktur und überall
im Land versucht man natürlich Strom zu
sparen die Schulkinder hier die haben
heute Weihnachtsferien bekommen hier
beginnt so eine feiertagsperiode für
viele Familien hier in der Ukraine ist
tatsächlich auch das Neujahrsfest der
entscheidende Tag der Tag an dem auch
die Geschenke ausgetauscht werden das
ist noch so ein Überbleibsel aus
sowjetszeiten und gerade hier in Kiew
befürchten viele dass sie diesen Tag
möglicherweise in dunklen und kalten
Wohnungen verbringen könnten denn was
schon auffällt ist dass es immer
schwieriger wird diese Zerstörungen der
Infrastruktur diese Schäden dann auch
schnell zu beheben
und lass uns noch einen Blick auf das
aktuelle Kriegsgeschehen werfen wie ist
da die Entwicklung
naja militärisch oder das eigentliche
Kriegsgeschehen konzentriert sich vor
allen Dingen auf die fronte im Osten
die Region Don jetzt bachmute da gibt es
nach wie vor schwere Kämpfe auch im
Süden rund um Personen allerdings gibt
es viele die glauben dass militärisch
die nächsten Wochen durchaus auch eine
Wende bringen könnten das hat auch mit
dem Wetter zu tun weil dann die Böden
ganz durchgefroren sind das heißt es
macht es einfacher schweres Gerät
Armeefahrzeuge auf diesen dann
durchgefrorenen Böden zu bewegen
Präsident selenski der ja wieder hier im
Land zurück ist der hat heute gesagt der
es gebe Möglichkeiten an der Front man
bereite Varianten vor er hat aber auch
davor gewarnt dass die Russen die
Weihnachtsfeiertage für neue Angriffe
nutzen könnten
danke schön alle nach Kiew
Putin verfolgt in diesem Winter eine
Doppelstrategie zum einen die
Infrastruktur der Ukraine so zu
zerstören dass Millionen Menschen gar
nichts anderes übrig bleibt als zu
fliehen wenn sie ihr Leben retten wollen
zum anderen hofft er auch die Europäer
zu zermürben durch neue
Flüchtlingsströme und dass sie aufgrund
der hohen Energiepreise so unter Druck
kommen dass sie in der Unterstützung für
die Ukraine nachlassen dieses Kalkül ist
bislang nicht aufgegangen auch nicht in
Deutschland das vom russischen Gas zu
abhängig waren was natürlich nicht heißt
dass die Folgen dieses Krieges für
Bevölkerung und Unternehmen leicht zu
tragen wären Beispiel Gastgewerbe erst
von der Pandemie hat gebeutelt und jetzt
noch die hohen Energiekosten Alexander
Pool und Claudia Vogelmann berichten
das Hotel leiners ist eine Institution
im Wintersport Mekka
Garmisch-Partenkirchen seit 1928 ist es
im Familienbesitz bereits die vierte
Generation führt heute den Betrieb
letzte Vorbereitungen für die
Wintersaison die Stimmung denkbar
schlecht steigende Preise besonders für
Energie machen Familie Leiner zu
schaffen
auffangen kann es überhaupt nicht wir
müssen einfach schauen dass wir es
irgendwie durchstehen wir haben
natürlich Preise erhöht aber nicht dass
man es so in dem Maß dass man alle
Sachen die da zusammen kommen können es
völlig unmöglich leider ist
Familienhotel ist auf den Urlaub mit
kleinen Kindern spezialisiert erst 2015
hat die Familie einen Kredit von 5
Millionen Euro aufgenommen um das Haus
auszubauen eine riesen Investition die
hohen Gaspreise zwingen die Familie
eigentlich zum Sparen doch das ist gar
nicht so einfach weil unsere Zielgruppe
einfach Familie mit kleinen Kindern sind
und die wollen jetzt zum Beispiel ins
Schwimmbad ein warmes Babybecken mit 32
Grad und auch die Außen
Umgebungstemperatur muss warm sein weil
ich will mich ja vielleicht zwei drei
Stunden da aufhalten will mit den
Kindern spielen will relaxen das
genießen und das kann ich nicht wenn die
Kinder nach 10 Minuten blaue Lippen
haben also Energiespar Chancen haben wir
relativ wenig mit ihren Sorgen steht
Familie Leiner nicht allein da in einer
Umfrage des Deutschen Hotel- und
gaststättenverbands geben 30% der
Betriebe an dass Ihre Energiekosten 40
bis 100% über dem Vorjahresniveau liegen
auch das Weihnachtsgeschäft wird wohl
kaum Abhilfe schaffen 60% der
Unternehmen rechnen mit einer
schlechteren Wintersaison als im Jahr
2019 also vor der corona-krise und wenn
die Gäste dann wiederkommen kämpft
Monika leider noch mit einem weiteren
Problem
gibt es definitiv es ist schwierig Leute
zu finden die ausgebildet sind und auch
noch Lust haben in dem Beruf zu arbeiten
der Beruf hat einfach wahnsinnig
schlechtes
wir versuchen halt jetzt immer
ausländische Kräfte reinzuziehen den
alles beizubringen und da unseren
eigenen Stamm zu bilden seit einiger
Zeit arbeitet auch Michelle Ritter im
elterlichen Betrieb sie wird das Hotel
einmal übernehmen und wäre dann die
fünfte Generation doch mit Blick auf die
Energierechnung wird die Tochter
nachdenklich
macht schon schlaflose Nächte man muss
halt irgendwie schauen dass man weiter
macht und ans positive denkt wir sind
positive Menschen wir versuchen da immer
irgendwie dran zu glauben dass man es
schaffen kann die beschlossene
gaspreisbremse wäre zumindest ein Anfang
in Paris wurden heute drei Menschen
erschossen die Bürgermeisterin der Stadt
bezeichnet den mutmaßlichen Täter als
Rechtsextremisten damit wir das jetzt
eine Nachrichten weiter Heinz
Frankreichs Präsident macron hat die Tat
verurteilt die Kurden in Frankreich sein
mitten in Paris das Ziel eines
niederträchtigen Angriffs geworden so
macron der Täter hatte in und vor einem
kurdischen Kulturzentrum in einem
Stadtteil nahe des Zentrums die drei
Menschen mit Schüssen getötet drei
weitere wurden verletzt der Täter soll
laut Staatsanwaltschaft ein 69 Jahre
alter Franzose sein der vor kurzem aus
dem Gefängnis entlassen worden war
nachdem er zuvor Migranten angegriffen
habe mehrere Stunden nach der Tat kam es
dort zu Ausschreitungen zwischen
kurdischen Demonstranten und der Polizei
in Washington hat der Kongressausschuss
zum Sturm auf das Kapitol nach rund
eineinhalb Jahren seinen
Abschlussbericht vorgelegt eine der
Empfehlungen darin ist Donald Trump von
einer weiteren Präsidentschaft
auszuschließen zuvor hatte das Gremium
bereits ein strafrechtliches Vorgehen
gegen den Ex-Präsidenten empfohlen am 6
Januar 2021 hatten Anhänger Trumps das
Kapitol gestürmt in dem gerade der
Wahlsieg von Joe beiden beglaubigt
werden sollte
das US-Parlament hat heute den
Haushaltsentwurf für das kommende Jahr
und damit auch weitere Milliardenhilfen
beschlossen vorgesehen sind für die
weitere Unterstützung der Ukraine darin
45 Milliarden Dollar das ist mehr als
Präsident beiden zuletzt gefordert hatte
insgesamt hat der neue Etat ein Volumen
von 1,7 Billionen US-Dollar
die Bundesregierung stoppt iranhilfen
das Wirtschaftsministerium teilte mit
wegen der sehr ernsten Lage würden
außenwirtschaftliche Förderinstrumente
sowie
Wirtschaftskooperationen ausgesetzt
betroffen sein unter anderem
exportkredit und Investitionsgarantien
hintergrund ist das gewaltsame Vorgehen
iranischer Sicherheitskräfte gegen
Demonstranten
nach der Festnahme eines
bnd-mitarbeiters haben deutsche
Politiker mit Besorgnis reagiert
Justizminister Buschmann erklärte wenn
sich der Verdacht bestätige sei hier ein
wichtiger Schlag gegen russische
Spionage gelungen das zeige wie wachsam
wir sein müssen neue Details zu dem Fall
sind nicht mitgeteilt worden der
Bundesnachrichtendienst will sich mit
Rücksicht auf die laufenden Ermittlungen
bis auf weiteres nicht öffentlich zu
Einzelheiten äußern
das Landgericht Frankfurt am Main hat
den abgewählten Oberbürgermeister
Feldmann zu einer Geldstrafe von 21.000
Euro verurteilt fällt man habe sich in
zwei Fällen der Vorteilsannahme schuldig
gemacht so das Gericht bei dem Verfahren
ging es umfeldmanns enge Beziehungen zur
Arbeiterwohlfahrt Frankfurt AWO Feldmann
wäre nach diesem Urteil vorbestraft wenn
es rechtskräftig wird seine Anwälte
prüfen ob sie in Revision gehen
das Oberlandesgericht München
verurteilte heute einen 28-jährigen Mann
zu 14 Jahren Haft er hatte vor gut einem
Jahr in einem ICE 4 Reisende mit einem
Messer zum Teil schwer verletzt der
Angeklagte hätte die Tat aus einem
dschihadistisch islamistischen Motiv
heraus verübt und sei schuldfähig so das
Gericht es verurteilte ihn wegen
versuchten Mordes und gefährlicher
Körperverletzung die Verteidigung
kündigte Revision an
Chinesen gehen in einen harten Corona
Winter dass das Regime ausgerechnet zum
Winter seine Kehrtwende in der
corona-politik vollzogen dürfte die
Folgen noch verschärfen und warum man so
radikal umsteuert anstatt schrittweise
zu lockern und die Verbreitung und
Krankenhäuser Belastung zu verlangsamen
bleibt auch das Geheimnis der
Staatsführung in Shanghai etwa rechnet
man nun damit dass ich bis Jahresende
die Hälfte der 25 Millionen Einwohner
infizieren wird das städtische
Krankenhaus hat sein Personal auf einen
Zitat tragischen Kampf eingestimmt die
Mediziner wissen nur zu gut dass Chinas
Bevölkerung eher alt ist und gerade
unter den alten die Impfquote niedrig
ist außerdem sind die chinesischen
Impfstoffe weniger wirksam und nicht in
omikon angepasst Alexandra vacan
Leichensack an Leichensack Bilder die
aus dem Beerdigungsinstitut in
chunking-stamm sollen im Südwesten von
China
vor diesem Krematorium in Peking stauen
sich die Leichenwagen
die Krankenhäuser überfüllt in der
Notaufnahme hier in der Region Hunan
haben sie gerade fast 300 Patienten
täglich
einige der älteren Patienten sind in
einem ernsten Zustand deshalb stehen wir
unter einem ziemlich großen Druck
nach der Null corvette-politik rollt
jetzt die corona-welle über das große
Land das eine Problem ist dass die
Impfstoffe eben den mRNA Impfstoffen die
im Westen angewendet worden sind
hauptsächlich unterlegen sind dann haben
die Chinesen als erstes eben nicht wie
bei uns die älteren Menschen also die
gefährdetsten Menschen geimpft jetzt
aber steige die Impfquote der Impfstoff
der der angepasst versichert die
Sprecherin des Außenministeriums der
Welt doch mit schätzungsweise einer
Millionen Infektionen am Tag wächst die
Angst von neuen gefährlichen
corona-varianten das soll chinesische
Gesundheitsbehörden jetzt genauer in den
Blick nehmen die neue Welle auch eine
Gefahr für Deutschland
in der deutschen Bevölkerung zum
Beispiel haben über 95% Antikörper und
alle die die Infektion schon
durchgemacht haben vor allen Dingen dann
auch nach Impfung die haben auch noch
zusätzlich einen andere einen anderen
Schutz durchs Immunsystem nämlich
sogenannte T-Zellen und die führen dazu
dass wir nicht mehr schwer erkranken
können
corona-chaos dagegen in China jetzt
drängt die Regierung
Medikamentenhersteller dazu schneller
Schmerzmittel zu produzieren
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit dem Blick
auf die deutsche Wirtschaft
mitten im Weihnachtsgeschäft gibt es
neue Schlagzeilen um Galeria Karstadt
Kaufhof und wie es bei den
Warenhauskonzern weitergeht und mit
seinen Filialen da gab es einen
interessanten Valerie Haller und jetzt
jetzt ist er abgesprungen büro.de ein
Internetanbieter für Büroartikel wollte
einen Teil der Filialen übernehmen der
Rückzug wurde jetzt damit begründet dass
es Meldungen über einen größeren
Personalabbau und die Schließung von
vielen Filialen gegeben habe laut
büro.de ein fatales Zeichen offenbar gab
es da die Sorge dass deshalb viele
Galeria Mitarbeiter nun freiwillig gehen
und für den Nachfolger dann nicht
ausreichen qualifiziertes Personal
verfügbar sein der Betriebsrat nannte
die Entscheidung frustrierend da bleibt
die Frage wie geht's weiter ja Galeria
muss sich jetzt nach neuen Interessenten
umschauen die gibt es wohl und mit ihnen
wird über einzelne Standorte verhandelt
ein erstes über Wärme Angebot liegt
offenbar auch schon vor doch selbst das
so wichtige Weihnachtsgeschäft läuft
nicht besonders gut immer noch
schlechter als in den Zeiten vor Corona
im Oktober hatte Galeria Insolvenz
angemeldet immer noch ist unklar welche
und wie viele der 131 Filialen schließen
müssen laut Insolvenzverwalter aber wird
nur ein harter Kern an Kaufhäusern übrig
bleiben offenbar gibt es Gespräche mit
den Vermietern da geht es neben der
Miete auch um eine mögliche
Verkleinerung der Mietfläche ob ein
Standort enthalten bleibt hängt wohl
auch stark von diesen Gesprächen ab ja
und damit ist die Zukunft der letzten
großen deutschen Kaufhauskette nach wie
vor ungewiss klare Aussagen soll es erst
im Januar geben und so lange müssen die
über 17.000 Galeria Beschäftigten weiter
um ihre jobsangen
vielen Dank
in Großbritannien sind heute
Mitarbeitende des Grenzschutzes in
Streik getreten vor allem bei der
Einreise an Bahn und Flughäfen kam es zu
großen Warteschlangen und Zeiten
trotzdem will Premierminister sunak
weiter nicht über höhere Gehälter
verhandeln auch in Frankreich wird
gestreikt etwa die Hälfte aller
Schaffnerinnen und Schaffner wollte die
Arbeit niederlegen der Bahnstreik soll
über die Weihnachtsfeiertage andauern
über ein Drittel der geplanten
Bahnverbindungen wurden abgesagt wie das
Bahnunternehmen es in CF mitteilte die
Streitenden fordern eine bessere
Bezahlung und mehr Personal
es gibt auch heute abend aktuelle
Unwetterwarnungen des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes vor ergiebigen Dauerregen
in Teilen von Bayern
zwei Meldungen vom Sport handball-bundes
Trainer Gislason hat den
nationalmannschaftskader für die WM in
Polen und Schweden bekannt gegeben eine
Mischung aus routinierten und jungen
Spielern angeführt wird das Team wieder
von Kapitän Johannes Golla ihre Knorr
ist mit 22 Jahren der jüngste Spieler in
der Mannschaft die WM beginnt am 11
Januar
im Ski Weltcup ist Linus Strasser beim
Nachtslalom in Madonna di campigo
gestern Abend Dritter geworden der
Münchner holte damit seinen ersten
Podestplatz in dieser Saison und auch
die WM-Qualifikation Straße hat er am
Ende nur einen Rückstand von 1800 auf
den Sieger Daniel Jul aus der Schweiz 2
wurde der Norweger Henry christopherson
jeder kennt die Musik von Ennio
Morricone mindestens die Filmmusik mit
der Welt berühmt wurde spiel mir das
Lied vom Tod aber er hat ja Zeit seines
langen Lebens so viel mehr komponiert
allein mehr als 500 filmkompositionen
ein Getriebener und Perfektionist der
dem Kino einen ganz neuen Klang gab 2020
ist der gestorben und ist sein Leben
selbst Stoff für die große Leinwand
geworden ein bewegender Dokumentarfilm
über den Maestro nicht nur ein
Lebensbild liebevoll in Szene gesetzt
von einem Weggefährten sondern auch eine
Reise durch die Geschichte des Kinos
hat den Film schon gesehen
[Musik]
dramatisch aber lustig das gefiel mir
er revolutionierte die Filmmusik machte
aus dir eine ganz eigene Kunstform das
war die kreativste Filmmusik die ich je
gehört hatte die einzige die ich gleich
nach dem Kino kaufen musste
Ennio Morricone
seine Melodien machten selbst harte Film
Cowboys ganz weich es will die Musik
ging sogar mir Nachteil und das will was
heißen
[Musik]
spiel mir das Lied vom Tod aus dem Jahr
bis heute unvergesslich diese Musik
hörten wir für den Rest unseres Lebens
siehob sich ins Gewebe unseres Alltags
ein
mehr als 500 Soundtracks stammen aus
seiner Feder Ennio Morricone der Maestro
gewährt auch einen Blick auf den Mann
hinter dem Werk
anfangs dachte ich es sei unter meiner
Würde Musik fürs Kino zu schreiben aber
das überwand ich langsam heute halte ich
Filmmusik für eine vollwertige Gattung
der zeitgenössischen Musik
geboren 1928 in Rom wollte der kleine
ENJO eigentlich Arzt werden der Vater
zwang ihn aber Trompete zu studieren
zusammen mit seinem Schulfreund
Regisseur Sergio Leone hier links wurde
der Musiker wieder Willen zur
kino-legende
eines ihrer Meisterwerke es war einmal
in Amerika
spätestens da verneigten sich die
Kritiker mit Oskar-Preisträger Giuseppe
tonnatore verband ihn seit Cinema
Paradiso eine Freundschaft tornadore
wird mit der ihm jetzt diesen
Dokumentarfilm Hollywood würdigte
Morricone lange nicht 2007 bekam er
endlich einen Oscar fürs Lebenswerk 2016
gewann er dann noch einen für Tarantinos
the hateful eight
[Musik]
and you Morricone ist mein
Lieblingskomponist und ich spreche nicht
nur von den paar Filmkomponisten ein Tag
ging ich rede von Mutter
und Beethoven über solche Vergleiche
sagte ennio immer warten wir mal 2 300
Jahre ab mal sehen ob die Leute meine
Musik dann immer noch hören wollen ich
dagegen bin mir da sehr sicher
bis kurz vor moriconis Tod 2020 mit ihm
für diese monumentale Bewegung ein
großartiges Kinoerlebnis voller
magischer Moment
[Musik]
das war es von uns morgen am Heiligabend
gibt es kein heute journal ab dem 27
begrüßen Sie hier wieder Christian
Sievers und Hanna Zimmermann auf
Wiedersehen schöne Weihnachtstage
[Musik]
guten Abend quasi direkt aus der Arktis
kam die kalte Luft die hier Nordamerika
geflutet hat sogar bis kräftige
Schneefälle und das wird auch noch so
weitergehen bei uns dagegen kommt der
Wind aus einer ganz anderen Richtung
nämlich aus Südwesten und wenn Sie bei
uns über Weihnachten Schnee sehen wollen
dann kann ich Ihnen den Bayerischen Wald
empfehlen da zumindest am großen aber
liegt noch etwas Schnee aber bei uns ist
es einfach mild zeigen auch die
Nachttemperaturen die sinken auf 11 bis
7 Grad nur nordöst sich der Elbe ist das
merklich kühler bei 4 bis 1 Grad und es
regnet noch kräftig weiter hier im
Allgäu der meiste Regen sieht hier
weiter nach Nordosten und von Westen
trocknet es allmählich ab morgen
Vormittag gibt's noch Regenfälle hier im
Nordosten und auch an den Alpen regnet
es noch das wird über Tag immer weniger
sonst ist es trüb ab und zu sehen sie
auch mal die Sonne Wind weht meist aus
südwestlichen Richtung und so bleibt es
auch morgen bei uns mit Temperaturen von
7 bis 14 Beratung in Schleswig-Holstein
sind Mecklenburg-Vorpommern bleibt es
bei drei bis fünf Grad etwas kälter am
ersten Weihnachtsfeiertag ist der
richtige Tag um einen
Weihnachtsspaziergang zu machen denn da
ist es in Deutschland meist trocken
Regen fällt am ehesten rund um
Nordrhein-Westfalen und Niedersachsen am
zweiten Weihnachtsfeiertag aber kommt
ein neues Regenband heran das sieht von
Nordwesten in Richtung Südosten in
Bayern bleibt es noch trocken aber hin
und wieder kann es sogar mal für ein
Gewitter reichen guten Abend